ni le froid ni le vent ni la pluie ont
découragé les aficionados du paris nice
ils étaient plus d'une centaine de
supporters à avoir fait le déplacement
pour approcher les 154 morts sur l'île
des impressionnistes de chatou pour le
départ de cette 76e édition va les
motiver déjà sous la pluie par les
programmes et dans tous les cas les voir
en vrai voire de toute l'organisation de
sa tour
ouais mais tu as fait beaucoup de vélo
en fête du conte des fans quoi c'est un
peu la fête du vélo moi je fais du vélo
pour le plaisir donc puis c'est
l'occasion pour les enfants aussi de
devoir tout l'équipement puis c'est un
peu la fête
c'est sympa même si c'est vrai que les
conditions météo sont pas sympas même
enthousiasme du public qui ne décline
pas depuis la signature de la convention
yvelines paris nice en 2010 ce succès ne
surprend pas l'organisation
c'est un département qui est juste à
côté de paris paris est là et en même
temps c'est la forêt c'est la campagne
d'affilée à tout pour pouvoir faire du
vélo le vélo des champions comme la
bicyclette en famille tranquillement
avec les amis sur le vélo cette année le
chouchou c'est lui julian alaphilippe
pour son troisième paris nice le coureur
français de 25 ans a pu voir sa cote de
popularité grandir auprès du grand
public
allez je veux dire même sens ça fait
plaisir ouais on est prêt pour la
première étape on va donner le maximum
si on croit qu'on aime on est ma passion
qui couvre son panache sa façon de voir
la course
ouais qu'il ait toujours au bout de
lui-même qu'il essaye toujours
d'attaquer et de gagner
voilà c'est un poil tu vas gagner des
grandes courses à d'année c'est sûr
julien la philly pourra continuer à
conquérir le coeur du public heavy noie
dans les prochaines années
le partenariat entre les organisateurs
du paris nice et les yvelines s'étend
jusqu'en 2021